it's so important for people to remember
that they're the creators of their lives
instead of the victim of their life the
victim is saying I'm feeling this way
because that person that circumstance or
I don't have any money is causing me to
feel this way that's my relationship
with money what that really means is I'm
using my lack to reaffirm my dependency
my addiction my conditioning that's my
relationship with money is that I put my
attention on money because I don't have
it the relationship with money is of
course built on lack and so when they
don't have it they feel bad what they're
really saying is my outer environment my
reality is actually controlling the way
I feel and the way I think so Lewis why
are you in a good mood today things are
going good why in a bad mood things are
going bad today so this unconscious
program victimization is saying that
we're allowing our environment to
influence the way we feel and the way we
think isn't that isn't that good
victimization isn't and the stronger the
emotion we have to our lack the more we
put our attention on the fact that we
don't have it so then the person has
forgotten that they're creating reality
because what they're creating is lack
let's create from the field instead of
for matter because a coherent heart get
a coherent brain relax in the heart and
energy moves right in the brain we've
measure this thousand times and all of a
sudden the person moves into these
beautiful elegant brainwave states where
they're super creative right the longer
you're conscious of that energy the more
you draw that future to you need
motivation watch the top ten with
believe Nation Hey Kevin Carmichael and
I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Dr Joe dispenza and my take on his top
10 rules of success enjoy
what does the synchronicity mean it
means whatever you're doing inside of
you is producing that effect outside of
you pay attention to what you did again
so generate a little bit more abundance
just do it for an experiment now when
the synchronicity happens do you think
you feel suffering or do you think you
feel a little excitement you feel
inspired right so then that
synchronicity is saying use this energy
use this feeling it should be easier for
you to feel this now and go back and do
it again let's keep the experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then we generate abundance that's
that's how we do it and the relationship
doesn't just happen by accident we
generate we generate abundance right so
then if you have an hour meditation
where you're tuning into your abundant
future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change you defaulted and
you're back to the old energy and if you
say it's that person or that
circumstances or that bank account I'm
going to say you're back to the
unconscious program being a victim right
and so then so then
so then let's go a step further
if your personality creates your
personal reality and it does and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life
nothing big there which means if you
want to change your personal reality
you're going to have to change your
personality right nothing changes in
your life until you change rule number
two don't let others control you don't
expect
anything in your life to change if your
environment
is controlling your feelings and
thoughts and if your environment is
controlling how you feel and think and I
say to you Aubry why are you so upset
today oh well this person's upsetting me
what you're really saying is that person
is controlling your feelings and your
thoughts and that means you're a victim
to your environments well to turn that
around and you start realizing your
feelings and thoughts create your
environment
and you start seeing the effects of you
at cause
you're going to react less the people in
your life because you're going to
understand that you'll be back to the
victim Consciousness and and when you
start seeing that you're creating
outcomes in your life you're going to
believe more that you're the creator of
your life unless the victim of your life
and I say the more you practice it
the better you get at it rule number
three become more self-aware when you're
at a greater level of awareness
everything seems to be more connected
that's what the quantum is so you're
playing at that level the
synchronicities the serendipities the
coincidences are actually informing you
that you actually are creating your life
and that's the difference between being
the victim of your life and being the
creator of your life because when the
environment is controlling the way we
feel and the way we think some person
some circumstance some condition what
does that really mean that means that
person or circumstance is actually
causing me to think and feel a certain
way and and I I don't think I have any
control of it then I must be victim to
that circumstance right and that's a
program right yeah so so I I realize in
my own Journey also that
if I don't change my response
to things in my life I'll never change
so so it's not even it's not that you
responded the question really is how
long right so when you become aware that
your environment is controlling how you
think and feel and your response changes
watch out because that now you no longer
belong to the Past you actually belong
to the Future so get a coherent heart we
know how to do that really well get a
coherent brain we can do that really
well have people take all their
attention on off the material world of
everything known go from a convergent
Focus to a diversion Focus we've got the
data to prove that if you keep putting
your attention on nothing on Space
somehow the brain gets highly organized
so now brain coherence heart coherence
you synchronize your energy to whatever
it is you want and you got to sustain
that state you can't we've had people
that have healed themselves from
Parkinson's disease from cancers
from ALS literally remission of the
condition and then have bad news
and in one hour driving to the hospital
all of their symptoms came back after
being completely healed for two years
That's How Strong those emotions are
right so so so in your circumstance
right
I want people
I want people to have those moments
where they have to literally choose
because I think
when it's the hardest it matters the
most that's what I think so so all those
things where you're agitated with the
person having their moment you know that
could be you having your moment right
and you would want someone like that
person doesn't want to do that they're
just having their thing rule number four
change your old personality how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being if you take a thought and
a feeling a thought and a feeling a
thought and a feeling of thought and a
feeling it's called an attitude this is
a good thoughts with a series of Good
Feelings you say I have a good attitude
today in a series of negative thoughts
that are connected to a series of
negative feelings you say I'm a bad
attitude today so attitudes are just
shortened states of being good attitude
in the morning bad attitude in the
afternoon if you take an attitude and
attitude imagine you keep those up any
string attitudes together you create
what's called a belief and a belief is
just an extended state of being so if
you keep thinking the same thought you
keep hard wiring in the brain you keep
feeling the same feeling you keep
conditioning in your body the redundancy
of that cycle over and over again
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of that belief and all
beliefs
our subconscious states of being okay
take a belief a belief a belief and you
string them together you form what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are right and
people are always feeling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this okay so
how do we change a belief or perception
about herself or our lives okay we've
studied this
okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story you
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took you
got the story in the half okay okay you
got to start telling the new story of
the future right you got to believe in
that future more than you have to
believe in the past so how do you do
that you only believe in the past when
you feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
of the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget now here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your voice possible no your body's
actually getting the taste of that
future event experiencing the future now
big explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lacking or lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five be in charge of
your emotions I think it's more
important to have fun I think it's I
play with this you know like it's not
that you react I mean we all react the
question is how long yeah and so so like
learning how to shorten the refractory
period of your emotional responses is
worth more than all the gold in the
world because if you can't control your
emotional reactions to conditions in
your life they turn into moods those are
one long emotion the temperaments and
ultimately personality and so then
learning how to do that and catching
yourself is the learning process and
that's so important for a perfectionist
to see it as like hey I did pretty good
I did I fell off the horse I got back on
not a big deal I'm going to keep going
yeah the person who says oh I failed I'm
but not good at this you know I'm gonna
get sick again that's that's a huge
default and that's kind of talking
ourselves out of change it's so
important for us
to realize that this is a very
uh intense process it takes an enormous
amount of awareness an enormous amount
of energy to master yourself in that
moment because valid Justified or not
the only person that is hurting is you
and when you finally figure that out as
my daughter would say living by this
emotion isn't loving to me and and and
we have to really decide is this loving
to me so so it turns out when
you teach people how to feel elevated
emotions they make some so many
wonderful chemicals that make them feel
good
that they're no longer dependent on
anything outside of them to take away
their emptiness their lack their
separation their pain Their Fear they're
actually learning how to do it without
any exogenous substance without anything
outside of them without any scrolling
through and there this feels way better
than any of that now that's the moment
where we're all of a sudden free from
our environment and and and people
self-regulate and when that happens
their health gets better they have a
headache it improves they have pain it
changes they learn that they can do it
by thought alone how valuable is that I
don't know if we could teach our kids
that it would be amazing rule number six
focus on the experience experience
enriches the brain now you're laying
down circuits for something that has
nothing to do with the material world
and that experience produces an emotion
but the emotion is not going to be guilt
or shame or unworthiness or fear the
emotions are going to be ecstasy or
Bliss and the stronger the emotion you
feel the more you're going to pay
attention to those pictures in your mind
and literally you're going to begin to
rewire your brain for the mystical and
when you open your eyes and you come
back to your senses you're going to see
a broader spectrum of reality you're
going to begin to see what has always
existed but you didn't have the circuits
in place to experience them because we
don't see things how they are we see
things how we are so now the person all
of a sudden opens their eyes and
I've had this happen you see colors and
light like you've never seen before you
hear everything's melodious everything's
unified so smell The Taste the feeling
of everything is just enhanced and we're
here
in three-dimensional reality for that
I mean we're here to really experience
life fully I mean that's why I'm here
that I'm not going to be guilty I'm not
going to be sad I mean we how many times
have we done that I mean that mystical
moment
um when you have that experience and you
begin to perceive a whole in a whole
different way
uh and and you connected to that
intelligence uh you will see that that
energy that intelligence in every human
being and everything around you and
you'll feel more connected and less
separate and I think that's uh and I
think that's why we're here rule number
seven start your day right 86 percent of
the people in the Western World the
first thing they do when they wake up in
the morning is grab their cell phone
that's almost nine out of ten people so
more than likely there's a good
percentage of people that are watching
this podcast or listening to it that do
that and when they reach for their cell
phone and they look through their
Facebook and their Instagram and their
Tick Tock and their emails and their uh
Twitter and do all of that they're
connecting to everything that's known in
their life they're actually making sure
that they're connected in a certain way
in place of that
you can still do that but before you
grab unconsciously for your phone and
start changing your chemicals in your
body it would be such a great idea to
sit down and before you start your day
just review the thoughts you don't want
to think
review the behaviors you really want to
change about yourself just review them
just go over them in your mind re review
the emotions that you feel the most in a
day and just remember that those
emotions aren't loving to you just just
review them in the beginning just so
that you're aware of them have to change
you'll start becoming aware of them and
when once you can observe them you're no
longer the program once you're conscious
of them you're no longer unconscious
right you're out of the program
before you start the day ask yourself
what how do I want to think today how do
I want to feel how do I want to behave I
mean what would greatness look like what
would love look like today what could I
do
that would be really cool for me at the
end of the day say wow so I had a good
day today what what would make me feel
that way and if you can't find an answer
to that start reading who reads anymore
read a book I read so many books a week
I know I'm that way too so read
something about you want to be wealthy
read a book about someone who became
wealthy and get get real and realize
they may have failed 50 times before
they actually pulled it off or what were
their characteristics what were their
traits What made them it's not wasn't
about their wealth it was about who they
became that's the key right so so so
fill your brain with a little knowledge
and then just start asking yourself
what's the greatest expression of myself
that I can be today and and and rehearse
it rehearse how you're going to be and
and then if if it leads to a different
Choice that's the unknown and just know
that it's not going to be predictable
it's going to be a little uncomfortable
that's where the magic happens if you
can stay relaxed and awake in the
unknown
things get pretty exciting when you're
back to the known you're back to the
familiar don't expect anything to change
in your life and if you say it's that
person or that circumstance
ah you defaulted went back to the
program of the victim allowing your
outer environment controlling your
thoughts and feelings if you truly do
this well
this is what I discovered
if I truly feel the feelings of my
future before they occur and I live in
that state I'm no longer looking for it
to happen how could I look for it if I
feel like it already has right so I try
to stay in that state because then I
don't then I'm not separate from it and
that's tends to be when the magic
happens there there's no control anymore
there's no predicting there's no
perfectionism there's none of all there
is is just kind of an experiment like
I'm experimenting to see if I changed my
thoughts and feelings if my life will
change and that should be the experiment
everybody has and and and do it with
with curiosity and do it with just
seeing if if the experiment works if it
doesn't change something else about
yourself until it starts to work rule
number eight build a relationship with
money I think we've been programmed
quite a bit uh in with our relationship
with money and we have a relationship
with everything known in our environment
you have a relationship a neurological
Network in your brain to for your
parents for your cell phone for your
computer where you live where you've
lived in the past what you're going to
do tomorrow that for the most part the
brain is a reflection of everything that
we know right so along with that is our
relationship with money and I feel like
I have a really good relationship with
money because I work on having a really
good relationship with everything in my
life did you always have a good
relationship with mine I think so I
think so I've never really lived in lack
that just wasn't part of it even when I
went to college and I had to take out
student loans and stuff I always figured
out a way to always be a little bit
ahead of the curve and so so
let's back up and just look at how
people form beliefs because yes most
beliefs
um are created from past experiences
right so uh children uh when they're uh
in their early ages their brain waves
are very slow like their brain waves are
in Alpha when they're like seven to
twelve they're in Theta when they're
like two to six years old and and
they're in Delta like when they're when
they're you know newborn to two years
old and so these brainwave States uh are
states that were really suggestible to
information so when we hear information
we believe it and we accept it we
believe it we surrender to it as if it's
the truth without analyzing it because
there's no analytical facilities yet
right the analytical mind starts around
12 or so 7 to 12 and that analytical
mind is actually what creates a barrier
between the conscious mind and the
subconscious mind so 412 roughly what we
see how how we model our parents
Behavior it's all being programmed
subconsciously right and so so that's
really really important because if you
heard money is the root of all evil
uh money is bad
only certain people are allowed to make
money you have to work hard to make
money this is how you got to do it and
that becomes the foundations
subconsciously like let's like write
recording an audio file you just keep
recording that audio file it becomes a
subconscious program right so a lot of
people have a relationship with money
based on either what they've been told
or what they've experienced in their
outer environment right so
so then we gain information from our
environment and the stronger the emotion
we feel from experiences in our lives
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more the brain freezes a frame and
takes a picture and that snapshot is
called the memory So based on an emotion
based on emotion the emotion Alters our
internal state so you're going along as
Lewis feeling really good and all of a
sudden you have this trauma you have
this crisis you have this shock and all
of a sudden you have this dramatic
change in your internal State and your
senses get heightened and then you
freeze the frame and you associate this
internal state with whatever it is
that's causing it right and that's how
we create long-term memories rule number
nine believe if your personality creates
your personal reality and that means
that if in order for you to change your
personal reality you got to change your
personality so the one of the basic core
principles of our work is really uh this
concept of change and what is change how
do we change why is change so hard
because we all say it's hard yeah change
is hard I used to say that too my
Kevin's so good at changing I'm not good
at changing it turns out I'm really good
at it yeah once once you know how yeah
and you understand the formula it gets
very simple to really all of a sudden
sip with yourself long enough this is
what I want people to do I want them to
sit with themselves long enough that
they can become so familiar with the
word meditation to become familiar with
they become so conscious of their
unconscious thoughts that they don't go
unconscious to them in their waking day
you know that belief like I can't why
can't I change or why is change so hard
for me
to become so aware of how they speak how
they act if they blame if they complain
if they make excuses they feel sorry for
them they judge people I want them to
sit with themselves and look at those
programs to become so conscious that
they don't default
and go unconscious again and then and
then sit long enough uh with those
emotions where you really don't reach
for the cell phone now and you're
curious to see what's on the other side
of it or you're given
a tool to help you get Beyond it right
if I give people numerous opportunities
to overcome themselves
because that's what it is and numerous
opportunities connect over and over
again sooner or later it's going to
start to create some movement so then
the person should then in that place
called The Unknown start thinking about
what thoughts they do on a fire and wire
in their brain and with intention and
attention when that voice is saying I
can it's too hard I'll never change this
becomes the louder voice than that voice
and nerve cells that no longer fire
together no longer wire together okay so
if I keep that up I can install Hardware
that can become like a software program
which would be like the new voice in my
head that says Maria you actually can
change it's not that hard
you you actually prove that to yourself
by getting beyond that thought there's
something on the other side of it right
that's called The Unknown
if you close your eyes and thought about
how you were going to be in one day just
with your family with your relationships
with your job with your co-workers and
traffic how are you going to be like
what would greatness look like if you
took the time to really rehearse those
scenes in your mind you would do the
exact same thing as thinking about them
you would begin to install more Hardware
priming your brain for the ACT
to cause your brain to look like you've
already done it that's what the research
shows so I want people
to remind themselves of who they do want
to be and get very familiar with it fire
and wire fire and wire and then this
Focus equals feeling right so if you're
focusing on it non-stop you're going to
start to feel it which is the next thing
and the last thing then is which is the
toughest part for people because we've
been programmed and hypnotized into
waiting for the event out there to occur
to take away the lack or the pain that
we feel inside of us so the event
produces the experience of when the
wealth comes when the relationship comes
out I'm going to be happy Well turns out
you got to feel it in order for it to
happen in the quantum so if we can teach
people how to self-regulate their
emotional state right
and feel the feeling before the event
the body is so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and the emotion that that person is
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's living in a new
environment well
the research on epigenetics says it's
the environment that signals the gene
okay well the end product of an
experience from an environment is an
emotion so when people are embracing
these emotions ahead of the
environmental experience they're
signaling genes ahead of the environment
especially they're actually their
gratitude is actually healing them their
wholeness is moving them back towards
Health their empowerment is taking them
towards success they're they're
generating abundance they're feeling
more worthy and and and it turns out
when we measure what happens
there are dramatic biological changes
that take place in one week
that actually suggests that that person
is literally living in a new environment
and they're in a ballroom and there's
not a lot that happens in a ballroom and
I keep saying to the scientists
where are those chemicals coming from
and remember 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is live with
gratitude that sounds really easy but
when it comes down to feeling gratitude
before the experience most people go uh
yeah I gotta go yeah I didn't really
feel it you know but the person who says
I'm not getting up I'm just not gonna
get up
until I open my heart to life now to me
that's that's a willingness so then as
they trade guilt and suffering for joy
and freedom and they and inspiration and
a love for life and they're doing it
without relying on anything outside of
them
they're going to be more prone to no
longer need anything outside of them to
make them feel that way they're going to
feel that way naturally and then
everybody's going to be really
suspicious like he changed his
medication he's doing something he's not
telling me you know you're going to show
up unpredictable in your life and that's
when we begin to become outstanding or
Supernatural or extraordinary but
you can't take
any of that with you to become someone
else and if someone says to me well I
really can't do it because I've had this
experience 22 years ago or 30 years ago
I'm going to say to you that event
had such a strong emotion
that you haven't changed since that
experience and forget about the
experience just overcome the emotion
because the memory without the emotional
charge is called wisdom and that's why
we're here so then you can look back at
the past and you can say wow I learned
something really great I'd never do that
again and by the way
when the experience finally lands in
your lap and you prove to yourself how
powerful you really are that you created
something by thought alone
and that event comes in a way that you
never expected that surprises you and
leaves No Doubt
that what you were doing inside of you
produced an effect outside of you and
you are exuberant and you feel worthy of
life and feel grateful to be alive that
you are in love with the moment
you will look back
at your entire past in that moment I
swear and you will not want to change
one thing in your past because it got
you to that present moment and that's
when it was all worth it that's when all
makes sense now you're free from the
past and now you're not you're not
thinking about the past any longer
you're believing in your future more
than you're believing in your past
you're more in love with your future
than you are with your past
we don't see things how they are we see
things how we are and so the I don't
like to use the word visualization
because I think it's been
okay has been overused I like to use the
word mental rehearsal I don't care if
you're a virtuoso uh musician I don't
care if you are a performer or an actor
I don't care if you're a dancer or an
athlete everybody does this who's
engaged in getting better at whatever
they do they will rehearse a course now
or the re rehearse the ACT enough times
that the once they can concept the whole
thing to its completion
and they get out of that think box then
the think box is so important because we
have to
review our act we have to repeat it
enough times and the act of mental
rehearsal really installs the
neurological Hardware in your brain it
primes the brain free so you have
circuits to use now mental rehearsal
also changes the body you can take a
group of men
and have them imagine or rehearse doing
bicep curls for an hour a day for two
weeks and add an emotional component
called stronger harder more intense and
for one hour they practice in their mind
doing those those curls at the end of
two weeks there's a 13.5 increase in
muscle strength they never lifted weight
their bodies changing by thought alone
so the person who's priming their brain
and body through rehearsal
when they get in their play box there's
no thinking they're just doing there's
just the act in fact the thought of what
they're doing becomes the experience
they get lost in the act and they're
analytical facilities they're analytical
mind is out of the way and they can they
can sustain a state where nothing in
their environment is going to move them
from the state they're in the feeling of
what it would feel like to play well and
they hold on to that feeling and when
the conditions get tense they actually
do something different they
self-regulate and they actually crave
this moment of performance to be able to
produce an outcome and so there's no
mysticism to this it's just what people
do when they get really into something
is that we rehearse all the time so
people understand if you take a group of
people have never played the piano
before and you teach them one hand that
scales them chords and they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you do a
brain stand and before and after they'll
grow circuits on the opposite side of
the brain no magic there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections get your body involved you
get some instruction you have an
experience experience enriches the
circuits repeat it over and over again
fire and wire and pay attention and stay
present you'll assemble new neurological
circuitry
take another group of people have them
close their eyes an act that actually
have them mentally rehearse playing the
scales and chords for two hours a day
for five days scan their brain before
and after in the end of five days their
brain will look like they've been
playing the piano for five days but they
never lifted a finger the brain
literally changed through the rehearsal
okay so now take the person and put them
in front of a piano never played the
piano before and they could actually
play those scales and chords like the
people who are actually physically
demonstrating it so what does that have
to do for the single mother of three
children what does that have to do with
the person
who's trying to heal a health condition
it's not enough to just have a good
meditation and get up and spend the rest
of your day reacting and responding to
the conditions in your life that's one
hour of living or conditioning your body
and brain into the future against 15
hours of you and responding emotionally
from your past so we got to rehearse
okay how am I going to be in this
situation how am I going to change
what would love do today what would
greatness look like it's the it's those
frontal lobe questions that actually
begins to install the circuitry and we
all do it naturally the only time we
don't do it is when we're living in
stress and we're living in survival why
because it's not a time to create it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
go inward it's not and not a time to
Dream It's a time to run fight and hide
and if you're spending the majority of
your time in the arousal of those stress
hormones
than most people then their senses
become heightened they narrow their
focus and now they're engaged in doing
anything they can relying on something
outside of them to take away that
feeling so if people begin to understand
that they actually can change and
there's a they understand a formula to
do it and they practice that formula and
they rehearse it both by mentally
rehearsing it and actually participating
in it the effects should be in the
experiment that something should change
either in your body or in your life and
that's why we do it so when you see the
changes or the synchronicities or the
coincidences or the opportunities
starting to show up in your life you're
going to pay attention to what you did
and you're going to do it again and many
people who have chronic health
conditions that just get Beyond those
thoughts and those habits and those
emotions that keep them as that same
personality and begin to think act and
feel differently
notice dramatic changes in their in
their health and in their biology and we
have the data to suggest that people who
do this for seven days their body looks
like genetically and biologically
they're in a different life their body
is no longer responding in the same way
and they're no longer victims to their
environment because they can
self-regulate there tends to be a
greater resistance
to anything in their environment even on
a microscopic level look people can
create all kinds of wealth and they can
create all kinds of abundance they can
have the cars the homes and everything
but if they can't be present right to
enjoy them I've sat with billionaires
and they've looked me in the eye and
said we're all miserable we're all
miserable and and and and and and and so
then at what point do you have to wait
uh to change does it have to be that
lowest point or or or can you learn and
change in a state of joy and inspiration
instead of instead of pain and suffering
and that that becomes the art right so
then
to change then is to be greater than the
habituations the drives and the emotions
that have been conditioned in the body
to change is to be greater than the
conditions in our environment that every
person every object everything in our
life has a neurological Network
associated with them they're knowns
because we've experienced them and we
have an emotion associate with them so
you if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future you're left with
the memories of the past and you see
your ex and you're going to see your ex
through the memory of your past
neurologically and it's going to elicit
an emotional response and you're
thinking and feeling equal to your
environment your life's not going to
change so then the next question is how
could I overcome that condition that
with my ex can I actually forgive could
I actually open my heart can I actually
the reason we do this is because the
stronger the emotion we feel towards
someone or something in our life the
more we pay attention to them and where
we place our attention is where we place
our energy and so then we're giving our
power away to that person or
circumstance that's vital life force you
could use to change the person who's
sitting in the meditation
and they want to quit this is they're
thinking they're doing their meditation
wrong I want to tell you you're doing it
right that's the defining moment right
and you lower the volume to that emotion
I guarantee you'll take your attention
off that person and sooner or later when
the body finally settles down and you
get Beyond it you're going to take your
power back and that's building your own
electromagnetic field now you have
energy to heal now you have energy great
we measured this now you have energy for
for creation the hormones of stress push
the genetic buttons that create disease
if you can turn on the stress response
just by thought alone
your thoughts could make you sick and if
your thoughts could make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts could make
you well so they began to realize that
oh my God the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking caused
me to feel guilt and I don't even know
it's guilt it just feels like me it's
just I'm used to the same chemical
continuity now the moment they decided
to change anytime you decide to change
and change anything about yourself get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable you're going to leave The
Gnome yeah you're gonna leave the
familiar and you're gonna step into the
unknown even if the familiar is
uncomfortable and painful right you
still can be painful leaving the pain
right because some people are super
happy being unhappy right so then they
would rather cling to their suffering
than take a chance and possibility so
these people said I really have nothing
to lose right
so then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable and be in the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so when the body is
conditioned to become the mind then to
change is to be greater than the body
right because we become greater than the
body well that's a whole nother
conversation but let me finish this okay
so the third thing they said was
okay so now that I know that I got to
break the habit of being myself and I
can't mismanage my thoughts and feelings
I got to change how I act I got to watch
how I speak I gotta become conscious of
how unconscious I am because 95 of Who
We Are by the time we're 35 years old
it's a set of memorized behaviors like a
computer program emotional reactions
unconscious beliefs and perceptions so
the first step to change
is to become conscious of how you think
to notice how you act to pay attention
to how you feel and the act of observing
those states of Mind and Body separates
you from that program now you're you're
the Consciousness observing that program
it turns out the more conscious you
become of how unconscious you are you
know letting imagine a dark place
that first step creates enormous amounts
of Chaos in the brain and body and it's
disturbing so people just go back to the
same addiction the same emotion the same
problem this feels better no that feels
familiar so they said okay now I gotta
change I gotta reinvent myself now this
is really important because they started
sitting down and thinking Okay who in
history do I admire we're great people
role models that I can follow what are
the qualities and characteristics that
they have how am I going to change you
know these are what we call frontal lobe
questions the creative center of the
brain switch is on an emotional Center
settles down
so then they started thinking
I have to be in a new life if I was
really going to heal what would I have
to change about myself
now there's this interesting phenomenon
that if you close your eyes and you
begin to think about doing something
you're an athlete you understand this if
you're a background in football and you
are running a pattern or you are doing
something you would rehearse it in your
mind turns out
that the act of mentally rehearsing
something when you're truly present
your brain does not know the difference
between what's going on out there and
what's going on in here in fact your
brain will begin to look like you've
been doing it for the last five days and
you've never run the course so now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
because typically it is now it's a map
to the Future so now you're priming your
brain so that became the very platform
you know experiments with piano players
you know you take a group of people that
never played the piano before you divide
them into two different categories
I think one group of people you teach
them one-handed scales and chords you do
a brain scan on them they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you
rescan the brain they grow new circuits
on the opposite side of the brain
nothing magical there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections get some instruction you get
instruction you get your body involved
get your body involved you're gonna have
an experience experience in which is the
brain pay attention to what you're doing
you got to pay attention and repeat it
firing and wiring here to assemble new
circuits you can take the other group of
people have them come for two hours a
day for five days do a brain scan before
the brain scan after have them close
their eyes and mentally rehearse playing
those scales and chords
at the end of five days they'll grow the
same amount of circuits and their brain
as the people who actually physically
demonstrated the action what does that
mean it means not only they change their
brain by thinking differently but their
brain looks like they've been playing
the piano for five days now set them in
front of a piano never play the piano
before they'll play those scales and
chords because their brain is wired to
play it so now the act of rehearsing who
they're going to be
what are the qualities I'm beginning to
get in this creative state began to lay
down the circuits of a new personality
and a new personality is connected to a
new personal reality so the next
question is does that change the body
take a group of men have them do
one-handed
curls in their mind and bring an
emotional component like stronger harder
more intense one hour a day for two
weeks at the end of two weeks 13.5
increase in muscle strength wow never
lifted away now their body is changing
by thought Allah so these people began
to reprogram their brain and body
and all of a sudden they began to act
differently why because they installed
the circuits they began to think
differently of course they began to feel
differently they they were no longer
feeling pain they're actually liking
themselves right so that if they're
living by a different emotion and
they're they're feeling an elevated
emotion before their healing before they
were healed they're not waiting for
their healing to feel Joy and gratitude
they're feeling gratitude and joy now
their bodies believing that it's healed
because the body's feeling the emotion
ahead of the experience if the
environment signals the Gene and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is emotion you're signaling
the gene ahead of the environment and
what do genes do genes make proteins or
what are proteins responsible the
structure and function of the body now
you're literally becoming somebody else
and now you're turning down the genes
for disease and you're turning up these
other genes so
I started to realize that this
reinvention process is exactly what
we've always done it's just that we get
complacent in certain areas of our life
and we stop we had a guy that we came in
a wheelchair at an event we did recently
it came in that Throne he walked from he
had ALS he walked from the back of the
room all the way to the stage walked up
the stairs out of that wheelchair on his
own I asked him he said I just I just
have to work on staying in this
emotional state because the longer I
stay there the more I'm noticing that my
body's responding he's not saying why am
I why am I not healed he understands
that the only way he can actually heal
is to change him right and so now it
becomes very practical right because
it's very practical I think it's
important that practical part of it I
think sometimes people think they're
disqualified if they can't explain
something they do well let me tell you
one of the interesting things on the
show many of the people that do things
exceptionally well that have been on my
show athletes or entertainers
really don't do a very good job of
explaining it yeah they embody it and I
think sometimes someone listens to
somebody like you who can explain this
and think that they're disqualified from
becoming good if they can't explain how
they're doing it but the truth is it's a
repeated experience that becomes
familiar for them without the need to
express how they're doing it right again
for me right this is your this is your
life is teaching people to do this and
giving them the tools but for the vast
majority of people it's it's creating
the experience a lot of everybody
everybody has done this at least once in
their life what did they did they sat
down and they said what would it be like
to be happy what would it be like to be
healthy what would it be like to have a
new life what do we like to be in love
and they ask the question instead of
getting on their cell phone and texting
someone or posting they actually sat
there and they actually said let me
answer the question yeah let me get
uncomfortable here and what is it that I
truly want what would I have to change
about myself to be healthy to be happy
to be well successful what are my bad
habits they get busy writing down
all the the choices they want to make
all the things they want to do they
start writing down all their goals all
their experiences and every goal or
experience that I write down in their
future there's an emotion they get
inspired they get optimistic they get
grateful they get energized and those
emotions fuel more thoughts and now
they're they're they're actually
changing their biology and then they do
something really really really really
really important
they start looking at the thoughts that
they no longer want to think they write
them down I can't it's too hard I'll
start tomorrow I don't feel good until
they start looking at the choices
they're going to have to stop making and
when they they understand when they stop
making those choices it's going to be
uncomfortable that's the hardest part
about change they start thinking about
the things they have to stop doing I
gotta get off the couch I got to stop
watching this I gotta stop over reading
whatever it is and then we've all done
this
and there comes a moment where you start
noticing that like you start saying hey
I believe this is this is actually going
to happen right and that's when you take
the foot off the gas pedal and you start
really realizing wow I was the resource
of actually making this happen and that
I changed yeah I changed in the process
so
the the exciting part about it you talk
people who created wealth who talk to
people who created relationships that
are talk to people who have created
Health they'll tell you my disease
my poverty was my greatest teacher my
past was my greatest teacher they looked
back at their past and now there's no
longer an emotion associated with it the
memory without the emotional charges
wisdom now you get to go to the Future
you get to create whatever your free
willed you you could be anybody you want
to be in the process anxiety is doing
this living in the survival when you're
living in survival I'll tell you this
when the survival Gene is activated out
of the infinite Potentials in the
quantum field
you'll always choose the worst case
scenario why because if you're in
survival and you're preparing for the
worst there's always better chances of
surviving if anything less happens so
people are always selecting the worst
thing in their mind and they begin to
emotionally Embrace that future before
it happens thought and emotion you start
conditioning so you're conditioning the
body to become the mind of fear you keep
doing that enough times once the body
becomes the mind it's a subconscious
program a person has a panic attack try
as you may to control it with your
conscious mind you can't you program it
subconsciously now you worry about the
next panic attack and now as you start
worrying about the next panic attack
it's the vigilance that creates the next
one wow now here's what's happening in
our work
people who are self-regulating and
creating these elevated States we have
we have heart scans of them sustaining
hard coherence for a whole hour during a
meditation then at the end of the day
they're still wearing the monitor it's
eight o'clock at night they're not even
in a meditation and for a whole entire
hour they're on hard coherence we say to
the woman uh what's going on here she
said I have no idea I was just getting
ready for bed and all of a sudden my
heart just swelled up it was so intense
I had to lay on my back and surrender to
love WoW instead of surrendering to fear
she had a spontaneous love attack
instead of a spontaneous panic attack
now I would call that the natural state
of being so then
if you're living by those elevated
States and you know how to feel that
emotion of your future before it happens
you're less likely to wait for it to
happen because you'll feel like it
already happened you'll less likely try
to control it you'll know that the
moment you lose the feeling you just
disconnected and you're going to make
your way back when you get good at it no
person no thing no experience can take
it away from you now you're empowered
and if you understand the laws of how
creation happens then you're less likely
to compete and rush to get what you want
you're going to know that it's going to
come to you and now that's the new model
of how we create let's demystify the
present moment okay people wake up in
the morning and they they think about
their problems and those problems or
memories that are etched in their brain
that are connected to certain people and
objects at certain times and places the
moment they wake up in the morning and
they start thinking of the problems
they're thinking in the past
okay now every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with it so when
they feel unhappy when they feel bitter
when they feel fearful now their bodies
in the past thoughts are the language of
the brain feelings of the language of
the body thought and a feeling image and
emotion stimulus and response your
conditioning the body to be the mind of
that emotion subconsciously now the body
is believing it's living in the same
past experience 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year why because
the body's so objective it doesn't know
the difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is creating
by thought alone important
so what the environment signals the gene
that's epigenetics the end product from
an experience in the environment is an
emotion a person's signaling the same
genes in the same way and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of your
body and the expression of proteins is
expression of Life another person is
actually headed for a genetic Destiny
and when people labor
for the present moment
and they take their attention off of
their body off of all the people in
their life all of the objects they own
their cell phone their computer their
car their house they're no longer
identifying with where they're sitting
where they need to be where they live
where they've lived in the past where
they need to go and they're not thinking
about the predictable future of the
familiar past
they're dissociating from everything
physical and material everything known
that is the exact moment we call getting
Beyond yourself okay now
when we're in that place then at the
beginning it's uncomfortable because
we're survival is the unknown you better
chances of survival and running from the
unknown but that unknown is the perfect
place to create from so in the process
no different than any rehab in our first
two days of our event really people are
they're basically they're basically
rehabbing from their emotional states
and their habits and they're sitting in
the presence of that discomfort right
and the discomfort is because the body
is leaving the known but but but
if the body has been conditioned to be
the mind the moment you take it outside
of its familiar territory it's going to
start telling you Ed why don't you quit
you know you're not really good at this
you know you're more of a physical
person you don't really want to do this
you're not very this or very that and
most people just get up when they do
their meditation they believe that
thought as if it's true now the question
is what's on the other side of that
thought can you sit there long enough
till that's no longer the thought you
accept believe and surrender to well
then wow the next question inside of
that thought what is the other what's on
the other side of that familiar emotion
can I sit and work with my body and
settle it down stay you stay I'm gonna
feed you you're not gonna die from this
your bladder's not going to explode
you're not going to go crazy and you
work with catching those thoughts it's
called metacognition if you're in that
95 of programming where you're
unconscious
and the first step to change is becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
you're so conscious that you would never
go unconscious or let that thought slip
by you unnoticed I want to understand so
you're saying the awareness of the
thought being conscious of the thought
has it somehow lose its power over you
exactly exactly because just because you
have a thought doesn't mean it's true
and if you're left alone to yourself
you'll start believing every thought you
think and that's the problem so then the
majority of people's thoughts then are
based on what they perceive about
themselves from their past or their life
right and if you catch yourself
complaining and blaming and making
excuses and judging someone else and you
say I want to be a happy person well a
happy person would never do that would
make them unhappy if you notice that
you've been feeling guilty for the last
20 years you didn't know it was guilt
because it just felt like you and you
want to feel Joy well if you can feel
Joy it should tell us volumes about what
you've been practicing doing right so
then most people give up because
they they don't know that there's
anything on the other side of it so then
the next question is
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain well and with
attention and with intention
if you keep practicing firing wiring
those thoughts you start installing
Hardware do it enough times and it
becomes like a software program and now
that's the new voice you program in your
head that said I can do this I believe
in myself and you've created to an
extent a new personality which can
create a new personal reality now here
we go so then the next question is how
am I going to behave with my kids today
how am I going to be with my wife I'm
going to be with my partner I'm going to
be at work I might be on my zoom calls
I'm going to be by myself how am I going
to what what does greatness look like
what is what would love do today now it
turns out that if you close your eyes
and you start imagining doing that if
you rehearse how you're going to be in
those certain situations the evidence
without a doubt shows that your brain
will start to look like through the
mental rehearsal of the act that you've
already done it now you've installed the
hardware keep doing it it becomes a
software program and you'll start acting
like a happy person no magic there if
you don't have the circuits you can't do
it so the rehearsal then
is actually changing the brain just by
thinking differently the brain looks
like the experience has already happened
now you have Hardware to use do it
enough times you get good at it becomes
more automatic now here's the hard part
can I teach my body emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can't feel
it because it hasn't happened yet yeah
that's the conditioning that's the
hypnosis so you ask yourself at the end
of your day I do this every day how'd I
do how'd I do today bro how'd you do
just do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it that caused you to
go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could I
involve my experience now you may have
to search for some answers of the best
model to build or you may actually have
a long contemplation and start to go God
the next time that happens I think I'm
gonna do this or I'm gonna do that or
I'm gonna plan my behaviors and the act
of closing your eyes and rehearsing what
you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you gotta close
your door you gotta take a break from
everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear and now we've given people the
tools to be able to self-regulate to
create brain and heart coherence and so
you see people say excuse me one minute
I just need a minute it takes some
breaths they get back in they connect to
the energy of their future this is
incidental compared to where they're
going so they don't fall from grace they
don't allow their energy to drop and so
yeah in the beginning it takes a lot
because it takes a lot of energy and
awareness to stay conscious and not go
unconscious but if you're persistent and
you're determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then won't excuse
themselves and say on a hard day
yesterday at a fight with my co-worker
or my ex or and I don't feel like doing
the work well that's the time they get
back on the horse yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else yeah
and I think that's Evolution we do have
beliefs that feel good to us because
those beliefs are based on past
experiences and those emotions keep us
attached to the belief chemically it's
in our biology and we tend to think
neurologically and feel chemically
within experiences then that are
connected to the past so when our
beliefs are challenged we hold on to the
emotion like Jesus had a brother what
that doesn't feel right you know he was
married to Mary Magdalene you know I
mean people freak out because they've
been conditioned and they want to hold
on to that because that then ensures a
future that they can rely on
when you step out of your belief systems
and stepping into the unknown
you are now leaving behind your past and
then so then do you have the faculty
and the ability to create
do you have that ability if not because
then in order for you to go from that
Old belief to a new belief then you
better have a plan and you better be
willing to have a new experience that is
no longer a wishy-washy belief it has to
be a very strong impression in your
biology it comes with an accompanying
experience
that then changes your biology to
understand you believe something else
but that's not the end either because
then you have the question from that
point
what is the next belief that helps you
to understand the next thing for example
let's talk about it on two levels and
time out here for a second I don't care
well you can go to 11 30 here oh
beautiful thank you so much it was a
good conversation so think about this
the person in our work
who I'll use a simple example
has a very very difficult marriage and
her marriage falls apart her husband was
abusive
and lived by the stress hormones for
extended period of time of course all
our energy is going for some threat in
our external environment she has no
energy in him her internal environment
for growth and repair no energy for
long-term building projects the the body
is in vigilance it's it's always anxious
she's anticipating something bad
happening all the time and she's got
food allergies to
everything
she's allergic to her environment
she comes to the event she does the work
it takes her three months and all of a
sudden in one event she has a
breakthrough and she's eating anything
she wants now she's changed her belief
about her past because she's no longer
saying I am this way because of my
relationship with my husband because
when you say I am this way because I had
an abusive father I am this way because
I had a difficult marriage I am this way
because I got fired from my job what
you're saying is I haven't changed since
that event emotionally
and so now you're viewing your future
through the lens of the past when you
overcome that emotional state a memory
without the emotional charge is called
wisdom
now you're ready to create a new future
because if you're still attached to the
emotion you're still attached to the
past and you can't create a future so
all of a sudden now the person has a
transformation
she had a shift she knows that she knows
that she's liberated from that anxiety
she's she feels it and as a result of it
in a matter of moments Banner biology
reorganizes to a new mind and now she's
I'm watching her eat pizza I'm watching
her eat a hamburger she's laughing she's
and it's and it's sustained
but that's not the end because if she
healed herself then the next question is
I understand the physics and biology of
what I've done is it possible if I heal
myself
but I can heal another person
now my my belief is being challenged
again now I'm challenging my current
belief is it possible well I don't know
I haven't had the experience yet but if
I'm thinking it and I understand the
semantic philosophical theoretical
intellectual information can I initiate
it can I apply it can I personalize it
can I demonstrate it can I modify my
behavior in some way based on my last
experience to have a more involved
experience and that more evolved
experience will be outside of my beliefs
currently but I understand the science
and if I can get my behaviors to match
my intentions and I've done it to myself
and quantum physics says is that
Consciousness is non-local will help if
I can create a coherent signature here I
should be able to do it in another
person
so then when the when the experience
occurs
now I have more circuitry in my brain
that's enriched I have a new feeling in
my body and I feel like a Healer I
already feel like a Healer because I've
healed myself but let me see if I can
heal someone else I'm going to bring up
that emotion and it may take me a few
times and I'm telling you that woman we
did a coherent session where we're
healing another person and the person
laying down there was a woman who from
London who had a exposure to a bacteria
in India 20 years ago who had food
allergies That Couldn't overcome that
bacteria and I watched this woman
synchronistically
unbeknownst to the woman laying down
there lay a coherent energy in that
person's body and that woman was healed
I had dinner with her in London and she
was eating salmon and rice and
everything else and she said I don't
know what happened but I got healed now
that person who did the healing
her belief was challenged and because
she had the experience she asked the
greater question so the greater question
then led to the next experience but it's
not enough to do it once
you got to be able to repeat that
experience you got to make it scientific
right you got to get it you got to make
it a skill and this is where people stop
like they have the one experience and
say I'm a Healer no
the fact that you have the experience
means you should be able to reproduce
that
so then you keep pushing the boundaries
of your beliefs that's called Evolution
and so people reach a certain point in
their belief systems and they stop and
so I think the problem with a lot of
people in the spiritual Community is
they confuse Insight with belief like oh
you know I had a I have an I have
anxiety so my reason I have anxiety
because I have a chemical imbalance in
my brain that's what my doctor told me
and I get panic attacks and I got a
panic attack on a plane and I'm afraid
of planes and crowded places and so now
that you know that you have a chemical
imbalance in your brain does it heal
your anxiety no so then they go to the
they go to the psychologist they go to
their friend their friends as well it's
not a hardware problem it's not circuits
and molecules and chemicals
software problem you know your father
was overbearing he was a perfectionist
and and it's a soft it's a programming
you know it's from your past and
the person now has the insight
that their father was overbearing does
it heal the anxiety but they will see
that as a belief like my father was
overbearing which they're really saying
is I am this way because of this past
experience so then they go to the
psychic and the psychic says you were
burned at the stake in Carcassonne in
the 1500s you're a Charismatic Christian
the memories burned in your soul now
that you know that you are a Charismatic
Christian from the 1500s a cathar a
Templar does it heal your anxiety no so
then you go to the astrologer and she
says you know America reason retrograde
don't leave the house for six months
it's the reason Ari the way you are the
way you are and so they develop beliefs
that are within their emotional
acceptance and so then they build more
beliefs within those emotions which
means I still don't want to change the
Insight doesn't change anything because
people will only accept believe and
surrender
to beliefs or thoughts that are equal to
their emotional state and they'll
program their autonomic nervous system
into that Destiny so then you get a
diagnosis from a doctor it creates the
emotion of fear or desperation you'll
only accept belief and surrender to the
thoughts equal to those emotional states
until you change your emotional state is
it possible for you then to begin to
accept believe and surrender their
thoughts equal to a new emotional state
and bring up the emotion ahead of the
experience now we're talking about
going against conditioning when you
teach people how to connect to the
energy of a future dream and be defined
by a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past to believe in their
future more than they believe in their
past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you
which also means then the moment you get
in your car and start getting angry and
getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less and less people are
experiencing the state of being called
being a victim so then if you're a
victim then you would say I was angry
because of traffic well then I would say
to you well you mean your outer world
was controlling how you think and feel
some circumstance some person something
in your outer world is actually
controlling your feelings and thoughts
that means you're a victim to those
circumstances but when you change the
way you think and feel and it starts to
produce effects in your outer world now
you start to realize you're the creator
of your life and the moment you start
seeing feedback in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life
think about this
if you spend the majority of your day
focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things it begs the question how
much of your time and your attention do
you put on that unified field that
invisible field of information that
exists beyond space and time and just
like when you're unaware of your nose it
doesn't exist and the moment you become
aware of it it exists the quantum field
is exactly the same way if you put very
little attention on it in your waking
day then it doesn't exist for you but
the moment you begin to become aware of
it the moment you begin to pay attention
to it the moment you begin to stay
present with it and to experience it
moment after moment and where you place
your attention as you learned is where
you place your energy and where you
place your attention causes things to
expand the moment you begin to
experience it not with your senses you
experience this three-dimensional
reality with your senses but you
experience it with your Consciousness
and with your awareness
the moment you become pure Consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people Beyond themselves and in fact we
know that after thousands and thousands
and thousands of brain scans that you're
at your absolute best when you get
Beyond yourself when you take your
attention off your body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go in time itself
the moment you become nobody no one no
thing no where in no time that is the
moment you become pure Consciousness and
that's the moment you begin to connect
to that field of possibilities called
the unified field or the quantum field
and that field in this invisible field
of information that exists Beyond this
space and time and independent of the
color of your skin your gender your diet
your sexual preference independent of
your profession your class the
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
your personality creates your personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this little video has created the
present personal reality called your
life
which means then if you wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life you
would have to change your personality
that means you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it it means you'd have to
become aware of your unconscious habits
and behaviors and modify them and you'd
have to look at certain emotions that
keep you connected to experiences in the
past and decide do these emotions belong
in your future
the beauty behind this is is that when
you begin to change how you think how
you act and how you feel you should
begin to see changes in your life and I
recommend that you try it out the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes a resource of
light and information and we're turning
it into chemistry and we're literally
robbing the body's energy right so so
then living like that for the short term
is okay because the body can move back
to homeostasis and then restore itself
but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain the limbic
brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
Messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as energy in these energy
centers and and if you're living in
survival why would you open your heart I
mean it's just not a time to open your
heart I mean if you're getting chased by
T-Rex it's not a time to meditate it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
connect it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fighter hide to change
is to be greater than your environment
that means be greater than the
conditions in your life to be greater
than the circumstances in your world and
every great person in history knew this
that means you have to be defined by a
vision in the future instead of the
memories of the past to change means be
greater than your body those unconscious
habits and behaviors and choices that
you've made over and over again so many
times that the body becomes the Mind
emotions that are connected to past
experiences keep you anchored
emotionally to the past and if those
emotions are driving your thoughts and
those thoughts are creating the same
emotions then your body has become the
mind which means that in order for you
to change you're going to have to get
greater than those emotional reactions
habits and hardwired attitudes that keep
you running unconscious programs and to
change then is to be greater than time
if you're waking up every single day and
making the same choices and
demonstrating the same behaviors and
creating the same experiences and you do
that over and over again it makes sense
that your past is going to look a lot
like your future and your future will be
more of your past finding The Sweet Spot
of the generous present moment existing
in that place where you're no longer
trying to predict the future based on
the past means you're in the unknown and
when you're in that place called The
Eternal present moment that's where all
possibilities exist give it a try
[Music]
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Dr Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there 95 of your life
is coming from observing the other
people and so your behavior isn't yours
how do we change these behaviors I go
first of all you don't even know what
the behaviors are because you weren't
there when they were being programmed